um but it's gonna it's gonna be fun
Ludwig is another character who really
is growing on me watching the the humor
that he has it's been um it's he's just
a fun guy to watch play chess okay so
the game is underway right yep so II for
just played right so okay
Ludwig ignores my suggestion he plays
pawn to e5 so he ignores what I
suggested which is completely fine if
this is what he prepared oh oh you think
you prepare this
he likes gambits oh oh wow so Ludwig
decides to play the Latvian gambit um
now we'll see right away if Ludwig did
some preparation here yeah let's let's
take a listen into his stream to see
what he's saying
yeah sure he said he doesn't have time
to teach me he said Ludwig
okay keep loitering Wow a good teacher
lottery well what's xqc up to
apparently my viewer calcio a lot of um
damn good advice so his one piece of
advice hurry wasabi in gambit but now
what do I do now what am I supposed to
do he car ooh this is not right at all
okay am I really gonna tell you guys
okay so I'm literally and tell you guys
what I wrote to Ludwig this I don't have
time but here's my recommendation Papa
platta is relatively new to the game and
he will go 1 to e 4 so I'd recommend
something slightly unorthodox confuse
him such as 1.e4 pawn to d5 the
Scandinavian defense or 1.e4 c5 Sicilian
defense well I think he mixed up the
pond respond with something lightly so
this is gonna be an interesting game
heater but it seems like he's kind of
okay well now if Papa pelota sees I
believe Queen each five year he's
winning
yeah I'm really confused by this this
opening choice by uh by Ludwig well last
time we had the interview phase in
legend
oh he plays 9300 no oh my god white
still in good shape of white please
queen h5 Chuck yeah has to see it okay
but this is gonna this is really wild
and I'm checking in on a pop-up lattice
stream and he's pointing towards the two
nights but I don't so I think he's just
too preoccupied trying to figure out
what to do with his nights to see the
Queen check I mean a lot of egg is going
all in here yeah this is a crazy opening
by Ludwig III this is yeah this is the
weirdest opening I think we've seen in
any of the games so far definitely is
and it's kind of funny but I guess it
doesn't make sense to get confused the
squares when you're just learning yeah I
mean I I think certainly it's it's
possible I mean I'm just
yeah maybe Ludwig maybe he know but
there's no way Ludwig can confuse the
squares he's the guy who played
blindfold chess there's just no way Oh
big our queen h5 played oh my god okay
um yeah this is gonna be this is gonna
be be wild um I don't think there's a
very high likelihood that both players
will wander but I guess we're gonna
listen in right yeah so we're just about
to listen into Ludwig I think we're
gonna go fullscreen there to see how
he's reacting to this very scary threat
okay this is fine right this is cool
yeah you just know if I go here he'll
likely go think about this think about
this think about this I'm gonna go here
then he's gonna go here put me in check
again and then let's seize the rook is
hanging with my queen not quite then
he'll grab the pawn if I block with my
bishop he'll grab this pawn but I don't
give a [ __ ] if he grabs that pawn cuz I
still get a I still get a sweet hoarder
Oh No
so yeah yeah we ball
was that cool that cool that a white guy
said we ball
I played rec six months they called me
buckets well I guess maybe we can go
back to where we see the board as well
right yeah so I mean Queen e5 is a
critical move he's got a question so
listening to him to his reaction might
just lose this game right here I rock
maybe he doesn't see it he pratas it it
is kind of a high-level find so I would
be sure okay I think this is going well
Hikaru yeah this is very strange very
strange opening choice by Ludwig for
sure and he's definitely a bad shape but
I would say if he can defend his knight
and take one of whites Knights he still
is a good chance to maybe survive and be
in the game yeah that's true but it's
very critical that yes he has to defend
the knight here or else he's just gonna
lose he's gonna lose without without
much of a fight right if if we see
Bishop e6 here defending his knight he
has a chance yeah so I mean he's gotta
find a way to stabilize where he's only
losing a rook for one night
if he can do that I think he's still
very much in the game but he's got to
find a move to protect his knight here
and he did just bring up there should be
six on his stream so I do think he might
see it so if he does play it what do you
think his chances of surviving are I
think it's still very close to 5050 I
would say it's I would say if he plays
Bishop to e6 his chances are probably I
would still say like four or 40% I would
say 6040 if he moves the King I think
it's very unlikely is gonna survive the
game but I
I think you should move the bishop here
okay well we're gonna see his decision
soon but now I see that he's also
considering King f8 so he does
understand his Knight is under attack he
sees the threat oh ok King f8 here
well Papa platta also has to play
accurately here but I think even the
intuitive moves like moving one of the
Knights away from the pin and taking the
pawn on e4 is a good move for him yeah
but the problem I think here is that
Bishop c4 is a very natural developing
move like it's an move that I think
everyone's been taught at some point to
play develop your bishop and castle your
king so I think it's it's definitely a
move that that Papa Plata is capable of
finding and if he finds the move I think
the game is over I think it's just that
simple
got it so you do think it's it's an
intuitive move he's likely to find and
actually checking into stream now he
found it Bishop c4 and how is he gonna
defend I mean if he moves the Queen up
we just take if he moves the bishop we
take there's no good way to defend
against this checkmate he can stall if
he moves his bishop away to make space
for his king yeah I mean I I mean I
think black here should probably move
the bishop but it's still really really
bad oh man maybe me you know Ludwig is a
little bit of a comedian and last time
we had commentary you know he kind of
joked that we messed him up with the
prep maybe this is part of a long joke
where he's throwing you know what I mean
possibly yeah possibly this is not not
off to a good start so in fact I knew
there might be a force checkmate here
for white in the next couple of moves if
you take with the Queen mm-hmm I'll draw
your 95 yeah that looks that looks
terrifying I guess actually the other
Knights a little better but right so
yeah I think I mean yeah so I used to go
King e7 only move
and the moves here for Papa platter are
quite intuitive right cuz he just
continues checking oh no worries raging
well I'm just very confused by this
opening choice by Ludwig it's not it's
not what I suggested I don't think
anyone's a seeking lessons with us
suggest this opening to him either so
it's a little bit strange I'm not gonna
lie I'm really looking forward to this
interview I think I think we get a lot
of in there the game is not over yet
though if Queens come off the board it's
definitely not over and there's still a
chance there could be a blunder well
we're gonna take another listen on to
what Ludwig is saying right now cuz he
it seems like he has a lot to say or not
a lot to say and more just to kind of
groove to the beat that works - mmhmm
right right yeah just just chillin just
relaxing it's a good way to take an L I
guess new idea if he if he little if he
allows me trade Queens no way this
homies gonna beat me in five minutes and
thirty seconds without his queen this
dude is queen desperate they call him
the simple Aires
look little areas he's so fun to watch
come on dude you're killing me
can we get him to commentate the next
candidates or six public lottery tonight
well on here it's the end of days my
queens comes out of everything six
because both players don't have a lot of
time either so wow this could this may
not necessarily over I would say there's
there still probably I would say like a
20% chance that Ludwick and when I think
even now there's no the factors are low
on time has to take your ID and like
it's a not to talk he blocked himself
off from his reaction it's a hanging
Queen I think that makes a lot of sense
to me clearly notices his opponent is
down on the board he hasn't given up yet
and even though the king is in danger
finding the the precise moves to
checkmate will take quite a time sink on
papa Plata right I think also the
important thing is that he doesn't the
main thing for public lighting here is
to not hang his queen or hang something
for free
as long as he doesn't lose a queen or a
knight or something along these lines
and get nothing in return he should win
this game but again he's thinking for a
long time he's down to four minutes
already
Oh like I said oh my gosh oh my god he
card brother Kingston Kingston you said
he was gonna give his queen and he
listened I said it was 20 percent
there's a reason I said it's 20 percent
oh ok Ludwig alright let's see one week
put on your serious face put on your
serious face and take the Queen put on
your serious face man put it on not to
scare you but right now on his stream
this is the arrow he has drawn on the
board
put it on put on your serious face
Ludwig kochu karu coming out okay we're
listening to him again
this music is perfect for what's going
on so if I bring Bishop to e6 and then
and then and then and then and then and
then he takes this and then I take this
then I can yeah I think Bishop t6 is
fine seems a reasonable it's reasonable
and it's AIT's it's great but it's
reasonable Chad I think we just lost he
cars so watching that no I'm here I I
have a different thought completely but
I won't say it there there's a certain
league term that I would use that I
think describes was happening here what
is that term I know I don't want to say
it shot knows what I think oh okay
so Ludwig is excited about the fact that
he's up on time it's good to see that
he's not you know at least excited here
and he survived he didn't get checkmated
this is true this is true now if he
really is glad that he's ahead on time
he should be moving instantly right he's
playing a little bit more slowly
he saw the threat hopefully he'll
develop his pieces soon as well
but Papa plateau just has so many so
much extra material here yeah I don't
think it's realistic for Ludwig to come
back here what would you put the chances
at now no I mean it's like 5% okay well
there's still a chance
so you see us plans for Papa plateau
just develop his pieces start pushing
his past bonds or he can go grab more
that's also solid right I think I mean
at this point I think Papa Platt is
almost certainly gonna gonna win this
game here I think it's it's very likely
that he will that he'll win so if
literally I hadn't played computer
complete chaos in the opening he still
would have been a favorite but he went
for that
terrifying line and pop-up Lattisaw the
critical move which I'm just gonna pull
up for a second here which was queen h5
so that was still pretty impressive
yeah I thought it was very good
performance like pop a platter the C
queen h5 just to bring the Queen to the
center of the board I thought it was
very very good so it's it's fantastic
that pop of cloud I was playing playing
well other than the one bad move that he
played yeah that's very fair and now
will he'll just need to play a little
bit quickly to make sure he doesn't get
in time pressure and forget or anything
like that right because he's down to
what three three and a half minutes so
he still has time where he could
possibly lose on the clock but I I think
it's extremely unlikely that he will
lose I think I think it's a very very
high likelihood that the Poppa platter
will will win this game I would say it's
like 95% plus and that's gonna mean that
Papa Plata is going to make it to the
championships bracket so on the bright
side if Ludwig is in the contenders I
mean he'll be a one of the favorites and
the contenders that's why I was saying
like maybe he's five heading this he car
maybe he confused your opening theory
you know what I mean yeah he confused it
he pushed he pushed the wrong
connoisseur the other one yeah yeah
exactly
anyway I'll move away I'll move away
from that comment so if you were
coaching someone here and your student
had the black pieces what would you tell
him I would tell him just move quickly
you're up on you're up on the clock here
and stop thinking you only have a night
in a rook yeah that's pretty fair
Papa Platt actually looks more stress
than Ludwig and despite the fact that
he's winning yeah well I mean I think
certainly Papa platta is much newer to
shuttin Ludwig he's also significantly
lower rated so I think to win his first
game against whiff door and then to win
this game as well I think certainly it's
it's much more nerve-wracking because
he's not expecting to do well so the
fact that he's gonna have two victories
on certainly certainly I think it's just
probably more more of a shock more of a
surprise yeah I think that's really fair
and if Papa Plata does win this which
he's obviously very likely to I mean
he's gonna have a tough time in the
challengers division it is so strong
yeah I mean I think certainly for Papa
plaudits it's gonna be very difficult in
in the Champions bracket he is in what
group D right I believe so but all taken
so I mean I think there's a certain guy
and a certain set of buys who are gonna
be very happy with potential matchups
I'm pretty sure that the winner of Group
C will play against the second-place
player and Group D so I think that um I
think that in terms of Brack that means
that that forsen is probably in a play
against Papa Plata in the in the first
in the first first round of the
Champions bracket if I have my brackets
correct which I think I do so so the
buyers are gonna be very happy
assuming that forests and kids together
but if I'm looking ahead and I assume
the Papa Pato wins this game that should
be the first time a Djimon out now
Ludwig plays rook to Fe which allows the
night for winning the rook okay well
let's see if he sees that I mean he has
so much material here I don't see you'll
see a check he'll see out of the chocks
I don't know which one he also has
Bishop a3 or 94 just a ton of good moves
here even if one is the most accurate
right so he finds the
check this is a good move okay the king
is gonna go to d6 because he doesn't
have other squares
I mean he missed one tactic I think one
thing that often happens is when you're
up on material you stop looking to win
more material maybe you get a little bit
more relaxed and overconfident right
yeah this is certainly triming I think
the only thing a Papa Platt has to do
here is he needs to relax and just try
to push the pawns on the kingside up the
board that way there everything is very
solid or no weaknesses in his position
so um so he's just yeah he's just
winning he's just winning here as long
as I remember to push the pawns I think
he is no no worries and I don't really
see how what we can win this game
honestly cuz nothing is under attack I
was gonna say it looks like he's gonna
bite through all of his fingernails and
you know just being nervous in this game
but well I guess you can tell Ludwig is
like he's like so calm that it's very
why don't we go normally not a calm guy
like this he's so calm and so chill it's
um it's it's rather strange well on that
note let's let's take one more look into
what Ludwig is saying we're about to put
him live his audio on on show oh that's
a strong reaction to one pun okay I like
his reaction because it almost seems
like he feels like he has a chance you
know yeah yeah exactly yeah I want to
end up here how do you get a night there
that's not how you get the night there
you go back to e7 bank voice of God
behind there yes bing-bang-boom
he has a lot of arrows on screen if we
could pull out its pulled up now great
boom how do you get a knight there I
think it's the one Square than I can't
go actually I read about this how I do
on a scale of one to ten what would you
rate that arrowing like maybe a three
okay not the worst
yeah so I mean I think what Ludwig is
also moving way too slowly here which is
rather strange as well I mean because
the only way from when the game is on
time so he's using way too much time and
it's rather unusual but certainly
setting himself up where he'd be a lot
of pressure first set of games I will
say that much and he keeps blaming
Latvia the opening that got him in this
situation
um what's the idea here Oh what is he
doing here
well you know social trying here but
he's calculating everything and this is
not good also using way too much times
connect though I feel like I mean let's
just say I'm not so sure I think I think
you should keep his day job right now
because I feel like the performance his
career there okay I think I think we're
back and we unmuted him again okay well
he's actually the one who might end up
flagging here I guess he can try giving
up all of his pieces and praying for
stalemate that almost seems like the
best shot at this point yeah I mean he's
just so far down the clock that I just
don't see it happening
I mean I don't disagree it's extremely
unlikely but if he's not resigning then
what else can he go for other than he
like quickly give up his muses and make
fast moves I mean I guess it yeah I
don't I don't even see a move I just
don't see a move I literally don't see a
move how would rule I don't see a move
well what about Ludwig's chances so you
said that he's gonna be a favorite in
the contender who else do you think
would be a pretty big favorite um I
don't know if there are any other
favorites and in that bracket seeing
like your papa platter hangs Tings okay
so so water it does take the brook
well even if he gives a material I mean
okay and see okay so Papa clatter still
gives them a chance to play in this game
like okay now and now we'll see okay
Papa plaid I wanted to mix it up a
little bit I don't know why the pawn
only moved
oh shoot do you think he thought the
pawn can only move once no baby
okay so you should push the pawn up the
board but now a lot of it take the pawn
on e - this is
oh if you would have taken I'm just
gonna go back to show your idea yeah if
you would have taken on a 2 and
threatened rook a 1 checking the king of
the rook he actually would have had a
chance and I think that papa plateau
would have just keep kept pushing his
pawn so he could right exactly yeah
mm-hmm unfortunately that's that's not
what okay so what what needs to move the
rook over somewhere to attack I'm still
not sure that this yeah I don't know
what's going on what does this not
remind you of like Caruana Carlsen what
are you talking about Hikaru this is
okay okay okay we're going back to
Ludwig's audio and now a lot of we put
the rook in front of the pawn he does
okay so we're listening in on history
but you joked
he's putting up a good fight here
[Music]
well I mean the planet for Papua Plata's
is straightforward like he could just
try to get his King to g7 take out the
rook and then promote but I do think
it's hard to see based on his strategy
so far which is just been pushing ponds
right and also I'm not convinced by the
way the poppet platter will know how to
check these so a draw is impossible
results here one two I don't think it's
implausible displays I really don't know
but we'll see we'll see he doesn't he's
blown I mean I I think the poverty
should be able to get the king and rook
against King but I'm not sure if he can
win King in because now I do this and I
take this puppy well he's actually
explaining what he thinks right now so
let's take a listing sure I still grab
that pawn that was so weird why would he
bring his rook down he's choking so hard
he card can you still watch yeah I'm
watching
no I'm just kidding like is this too
hard for you to watch no I mean I it's
not hard for me to watch what I kind of
in wanna see is can can pop a plow to do
this where he keeps a see pawn of works
against the king and rook against King
there is no way that Papa Plata is gonna
win this I would say but if Papa Cloud I
can get to can keep the pawn and and and
do it like that then there is a chance
but I still think a draw is is is a
possible that's Gooding possible results
here okay yeah what are we still so calm
yeah i mean i sees much calmer than he
was in the match against box box
specifically so i think okay now here
will he move the king up this various
move the king up and try to win the pawn
okay Oh what was that decision okay oh
no no no I didn't choke now hinky some
wins the game I'm sure a lotta sees the
win right is this smart or stupid I I
think so but then we're gonna
see your question of this he knows how
to check me right right he should know
how to check me with king and queen and
rook I'm sure that he was shown that the
other day I'm sure he must have been
shown to me right yeah I didn't I'm
sorry I'm just listening to Allah doing
struggle right now why why did they give
you hope just to take it away I mean I
could still see this being a draw though
I think it's still possible I will know
right away though if he sees the pattern
it looks like Papa Platt arises he has
to always check the king so the arises
that he always has to check the king
then he should figure out how to make
the Chuck me yeah it's clear he knows
how to me so it's gonna be Chuck me yeah
he's gonna Chuck me too easily here well
he sure kept the drama a little longer
the very important move so now it's
clear that he knows how to cut the king
from the ranks and he'll won the game
yeah very clear that he knows how to
make the checkmate yep we will see Queen
up to yeah yeah he he obviously looked
at this right yeah yeah it was right it
was clear right away that he would see
the checkmate so very impressive
finished bye-bye papa Plata all things
considered
alright well he oh my god she's
disappearing into shirt intense thinking
buzz I love the pure focus there yeah
this ending part was very very good bye
bye papa platter very very good very
nice finish I was very impressed by it
by the way that he finished a game with
the King and King the rook and the pawns
we're going to the Papa plat audio now
because he's celebrating
we did it oh yeah nice girlfriend is
there too too supportive that's so cute
oh very nice all right I think I think
we're off the audio now okay so I don't
think either of us could have expected
what just happened yeah I mean the whole
game was very very weird certainly but
it did work it worked out in in a pop of
klaris favor and very very nice win form
for the most part it was a very very
good game yeah it was a nice finish at
the end he did scare us a little bit
because he was up a billion pieces and
then all of a sudden he just had an
extra three puns but you know what I'm
gonna say he knew how to put on a show
yeah he played he played very well as
impressed by his ability to find the
Queen shotgun on the Queen Chuck over to
e5 the LightSquared of the dark swear
attacking the king and the rook so I
thought it was very very good what he
did obviously after that once he was way
ahead he missed played it a little bit
but he was ahead by so many pieces that
it was just too much for a lot of work
to overcome well chat we will be back
soon we'll be doing the usual interviews
and those are gonna be so much fun so
stick around and we are back we are
joined by Ludwig and Papa platta I mean
what a game this was Ludwig maybe you
can start and explain your opening
choice well you know great question Alex
I do learn from the best and so I asked
for some coaching from from from the
best I know Hikaru and and he hit me
back and he said Ludwig you'd be dumb to
not go f5 and so I did that through and
through and it just turned out it might
not have been the best play by the way
lovely I'm gonna jump in for one second
there sure very unfortunate you don't
have to very unfortunately for you I
actually I read out exactly what I wrote
you in the DM on the stream as your game
do you understand that set you know at
7:37 you work what times under you you
get 737 am ii car I woke up to a buzz
alright cuz I have a special ringtone
when you when you ring
it's the Kim Possible don't dinner and I
and I said all right I can't [ __ ] I
can't ignore this because I thought it
might be training and then you said no I
can't do training I'm too busy long
enough years I said fine fine fine and
so then and then I look at it and I read
it in at 7:37
it's 737 the cutoff is Newton you're not
a lot of message any shooting for a noon
this is the room it's been the rule
everybody follows it so I read it at
like 8:00 a.m. and I thought you said f5
and I was like oh that seems dope that's
like a it's like a cool gambit mm-hmm I
didn't know what the third move was yeah
it happens sometimes
does it happen you sometimes not really
yeah I showed this to someone else so
you might watch the video the you
should've watched it when I showed force
in this gambit but nonetheless um what'd
you think about the opening I thought I
was like I was like damn this dude is
dog what is actually I am I was like you
put his horses two apart literally
allowing me to pin it I mean this is
gonna be free I was like I wanted to
throw for content but I can't even do it
cuz he's not good enough and then he
brings his queen down and I'm like he's
even dumber because you're not supposed
to activate your queen before activating
all your other pieces and then I don't
know man I don't know what what voodoo
magic that was but that Queen worked
some pretty awful Claddagh that was an
incredible Queen maneuver have you seen
this before was this the first time and
you discovered it during the game I
discovered to them during the game I
guess yeah I found gravity yeah your
pieces fell pretty quickly literally
yeah and then and then when he when he
blundered his queen I did not see I'm
gonna pull up that position on the board
um yeah papa platter there was a point
where he could have taken your Queen for
free so Ludwig um did you see it after
you made the move No
I was because I literally said to myself
well all he can do here is trade or he
can move up to f7 that's it that's all I
can do
it's f7 or trade Queen and then he did
something else and I and my first
thought was like oh I'm stupid
what he did was totally chill I should
have seen that and then I was just like
all right what's my counter cuz I I'd
planned it out I had thought everything
through here's the thing do you know do
you know the phenomenon that's called
it's the GM the GM phenomenon it's where
GM's play worse when they don't play
another GM ah okay that's fair yeah I
was watching I was watching actually
moist critical who he was being coached
by someone this morning I think their GM
I don't or maybe and I narrowed its key
yeah yeah narrowed its key and narrowed
its key missed a blunder
all right the the enemy team blundered
the bishop and narrowed its key miss it
in moist critical saw it because geum's
don't see blunders like that and I think
that's kind of what happened to me here
today so you're a GM and you didn't see
the blunder because bob latta is just
you know an i am over there
I could not a phrase it better myself
you're welcome that's what I'm here for
so Papa Playa did you see that your
queen was hanging after you moved it um
no I guess not
I still see it now I don't see it now I
guess the part the part the part would
just take the call
no that's what I said well okay let's
okay so so I'm gonna just progress
through the game a little bit because we
were saying how Papo plateau was
completely winning maybe Ludwig could
play very quickly and beat him on the
clock
but then Ludwig was actually playing
slowly so we didn't really know what
happened there but all of a sudden you
get into the end game and there were
only three pawns versus the rook a Papa
Vlada what happened I mix I miss Ligue 1
and then blundered another and yeah like
I get one misclick but like seven
misclick scenario yeah seven mistakes in
a row you did it on purpose to make me
feel good about myself yeah cross my
goddamn hopes and dreams yeah that's it
that's that that was the strap here did
you get a little bit more hopeful to her
than Lou doing yeah what do you mean he
plundered every goddamn piece he had
found a few pods I was like no way this
guy knows how to pawn king push turns
out he doesn't so he just abandoned all
ships and target my rook which ended up
being five had a v' I feel like I played
it master were you guys talking about
how masterfully I played at the end
because I feel like I almost made a
comeback of the century hey Carla you
you were always way behind towards the
end but but we did have a theory that if
you could take all the pause and pop a
plateau only had a king in one rook
against a king that he probably would
not be able to checkmate you but
unfortunately you made this blunder
right near the end where you moved your
king up which allowed the king to attack
your rook and your king at the same time
if we go forward very nice believe it or
not actually a missile
we got like a world record of miss clips
between too early it's too early I'm a
PM streamer late p.m. well that's their
um Papa Playa have you practiced king
and rook versus King ruin games no I
actually didn't practice eight and came
at all so you've figured out how to
checkmate at the end without knowing you
know I tried something out and somehow
worked I don't know
well that's very impressive I think
maybe just walk but I mean to beat to be
fair there have been several other
streamers who like even when they end up
with like Queens and rooks on the board
they don't know the pattern so to find
that pattern without knowing it is it's
quite impressive so so congratulations
oh it's very very nice to finish perfect
yeah thank you guys so much for coming
on for the interview um you know I'm not
gonna say it was the best chess I've
ever seen but it was really entertaining
so thank you both for that Ludwick and
buh buh flat a good luck in your future
games